thank you very much for your presence we go
exactly to the questions and I take
here first afp so thank you
please tell us to whom you will
appreciate the question if yes hello I
make it brief and of the effect is a
question for the  president macron
can you give
details on the european political community
that you presented when
the state would be entitled to
participate in it in addition to the 27 member states
of the eu they are what all those who
knocked  at the door of places
will there also be those who are on the move
like Switzerland is that the
United Kingdom could be invited and what
would be its areas of expertise and
for you ladies the presidents
are you in favor of it too thank you
hello to all and thank you for
this question I explained why
such a proposal seemed
important to me in the moment that
our europe is going through because we can see that
they have a desire to aggregate
and  t to bring Europe together in
structure and on several subjects and that
at the same time we see
both ourselves and the European Union at
such a level of ambition for integration
that it is very difficult before
several years sometimes several
decades
of integrating this one is therefore indeed
for the cren for several other countries
such as for example the countries of the
western balkans which have not started the
procedure of accession to the
european union for the united kingdom it was
his  choice since he decided to
leave the European Union but who knows
indeed for all those and those game
I gave of criteria which fall
under the European geographical space and
which shares the base of values ​​which makes
our  europe this European political community
would make sense
I do not want here to define
exclusively the geographical contours and
which has a vocation no more than the
skills I have given some of them
for example by name that does not matter  ndicates
political coordination of elements of
collective security and it is
also a way of building this
security architecture in the European continent
needs elements of
energy cooperation because we clearly see
in Europe the interdependencies that
we have unfortunately the geopolitical consequences
what subject  energy,
infrastructure subjects for the
integration of these regions
and integration with the rest of Europe,
including the European Union, and the
movement of people, and basically
I am struck to see that with a lot
of  countries because we only approach
things
through membership of the European Union
gave perspectives that were too
long and hopeless but if we
look at the problems that need to be
solved, these are often the
problems  energy economic investments
the future for youth
transport infrastructure and so
I think this is a way to
respond to this from anc  rer these countries
in europe to increase coordination
with the european union without confusing
all the agendas here is the cost of this
proposal it is now to be
worked on i will take my
pilgrim's staff if you allow me this
secular expression even if  I am here on sole
concordator
for to continue to move forward
and try to convince the
governments concerned
here are
conducts in May that one thing of enough
all consists in stat photo like trees
for whom of the flesh one of the six chiefs
worth
to the
jump to them fear france has taken note of
eight shows
and
red lights and we read and
in
europe just like we have to continue
as applications
it is to be
solid
and
we fight
for example the bio or in exam
very deep
a second  question
please gentlemen
tincu sir my chrono
[Music]
of assassination
but neither
conference in
cairo
before a march
maybe on your first question
I expressed myself  as I say
as President of the French Republic
I do not prejudge the adhesion of all
the members of the council I said that I
wanted us to be able to discuss it
from June so there will be a
discussion  an approach
we know very well that they have
differences between the member states
that's why I took care to
say two things 1 if we want to go on
the basis of the work of the conference
towards a convention which  is my
wish it is necessary that we clearly define
the mandate and the framework
I have given some leads without
necessarily prejudging the conclusions by
definition of this convention but to
properly frame the process I have in any
case given what is my position  but I
did not carry out any consultation work
and, moreover, as a
rotating presidency that is not my mandate
and I did not formally commit the
European Council so we will have
a debate at the European Council  in
June on this subject  t I opened a
second end second element I would say
of procedure and preferred dynamics I would
say which consists in saying whether to
reform the treaties everyone is needed
but whether there are public policy subjects
on which we are going to make
further progress  treaty gives us voices
if we are put in check which are
reinforced or structured coordination and
there we can do it to a few what
we have nevertheless started to do so
here I am going very clearly on this
formally I believe then  that for
a year it is this format that has been retained is
that
there were no two
no invitations or other but it is very
clear for president michel that it is
the rotating presidency of the board  who
is there with institutionally the
presidency of the parliament and the presidency
of the european commission and that is
why a year ago it was the
costa prime minister who launched it and
i was there as a
rotating presidency  who was going to  see the
works is today prime
minister costa was there and i received
here but i think when we
do exact things the
teams of trainers at last year in
the constitutional sense and batavian
koskas an
exhibition
finally offers tours within the limits of
which are beyond l ouarsenis
everything is
for example
decided to take
one
last question here
hello everyone fed up there would sing for
tf1 lci my question is for you
Mr. President Macron on this May 9
very special day here in
Strasbourg when we thought this
what happened this morning in moscow would you say that
these are two models of
irreconcilable visions which are affirmed
face to face today what did you
think of the words of president
vladimir putin's speech and in particular these
do everything so that  the horror of
global war does not
repeat itself would you speak of cynicism on the part of the
president all thank you very much thank you i
think we gave two visas  ges
in any case very different from May 9
there was on the one hand a desire to
show intimidation and
a resolutely warlike speech and there
was here
in a broad citizen way the association
of two citizens of
national and European parliamentarians  for a project
thought of our future and that with the
differences and our languages ​​thus expressed
and music as I
said earlier as a universal language and of
reconciliation these are two these are two
different projects
the European project
was born from the war
and we must not forget it
and it was born out of our desire
precisely not to repeat it and therefore I believe
that this project of peace, stability,
prosperity I will add today,
social justice and ecological ambition
is a project  that we must continue
to complete to make more democratic
more united of the sovereign this is the purpose of
this work conference and
what we are going to do next
president putin
never in the commentary but assumed
a warlike posture
we
very clearly stood alongside ukraine
to help ukraine the ukrainian people
to hold on resisted to help them from a
humanitarian point of view to
also welcome refugees  we sanction and
continue to sanction russia in order to
stop and constrain its war effort
and our responsibility to obtain a
ceasefire without there being
an extension of the conflict on the rest of
European soil,
but tomorrow we will have peace in  build
let's never forget that and I
reminded you earlier
we will have to do it with around the
table and ukraine and russia the
terms of the discussion and the
negotiation will be set by ukraine
and russia but  it will not be done either
in denial or in the exclusion of
one another, even in humiliation,
because our europe did not keep the
promise
of the post 45 in 1914 because in 1918
we had  humiliated
so here we are he makes us  ut have this
requirement we know that the coming weeks
and months will be
very difficult but we are there and
our responsibility is to have this
same requirement in the light of our
history and above all this
European unity and for me this  which is very
important and our fellow citizens have helped us a
lot in this work, it is
now to be able to act and
take strong and in some ways
indestructible decisions for our Europe which will help
it progress in this context and which
will allow us to stand  alongside
the ukrainian
message is named there are
often large texts
0 by the democrats to the six months and
the midst of fear offensive in cyprus
weapons it would take
fresnes costs a bullet equal in
democratic rights of zeitun pastiche
of al-qaeda  prohibit frei ait fana
mili
thank you very much to all